local seo at the end of this lesson
you'll be able to summarize the history
of local search and how new technologies
have made local search a reality define
an AP and explain its importance in
optimizing for local give examples of
directories that play a big role in
local SEO and finally lists some of the
top signals that affect local search
results the search engines have put
massive resources into developing the
visibility of local and regional
businesses in the search results in
addition the massive increase in
prevalence of smartphones over the past
few years have made location-based
searches and expected everyday
occurrence
people expect to find results based on
where they are immediately here's the
basic idea behind local now for a long
time in the past
search engines wanted to be able to
provide results based on where you were
in the world in a very precise way they
were able to use this somewhat by using
the IP address and they could
approximate where you were but it wasn't
always that accurate what they really
wanted to know is where you exactly were
within feet or meters now this
technology has evolved considerably and
in a very short amount of time using
location technology like GPS and Wi-Fi
in addition the prevalence of searching
on smart phones accounts for more than
60% of searches every day these factors
now enable search engines to know your
location and provide incredibly accurate
and thorough options for your search so
what's at the core of this well it's the
acronym n AP
stands for name address and phone number
this is the most critical factor for any
business not just in local SEO but for
local it is critically important all you
need to do is on your website specify
one name for your business one address
and one phone number and then when you
put that into different directories like
Yelp or yellow pages or whatever you may
be using you need to make sure that you
have exactly letter for letter the same
name and the same address and the same
phone number unfortunately this gets
convoluted because the search engine
spiders index and classify information
business information can be classified
separately all because of the slightest
variation in business name or address
making it look like a separate business
now a human would easily be able to
identify the difference and classify the
variations as a single business search
engines can't do that yet start on your
own website specify one name for your
business one address format and one
phone number and then use that same
identical name and format when you set
up your accounts at different websites
and directories like Yelp / Yellow Pages
you need to make sure you have exactly
letter for letter the same name the same
address and the same phone number
unfortunately this can be difficult
there are a lot of different formats for
phone numbers certainly for addresses
and even for names any inconsistency
will cause problems again a human might
be able to figure this out easily but
using the examples a search engine would
consider this two separate businesses at
the same address or because the address
format is different it may even be
considered two different businesses at
two different addresses do you see how
that works so search engines do not
usually know that they're the same
business and this causes all kinds of
problems
so let's pretend that your address is
one two three happy Street Suite three
there's a lot of different ways you
could write this you could spell out
sweet you could use just the
abbreviation for it and there's actually
two abbreviations for sweet you can also
use unit instead of sweet but sweet
numbers and abbreviations are where
people lose their consistency even with
Road Street Parkway or Avenue you need
to pick just one version spell it and
format it exactly the same and use it
consistently then find all the instances
of different variations you have online
and go fix them the last part of this is
directories so directories for a while
now has been a bit of a bad word it used
to be a great way of doing SEO until it
got abused in fact it got abused and
overused and abuse was that people would
charge a lot of money so that you could
be listed in a directory and now in
modern days directories are not like
they used to be and they're not that
useful getting links that way and doing
link building through directories it's
not going to be greatly helpful however
the big exception to this is with local
SEO there are important heipiess
internet Yellow Pages there are also
things like Yelp or Urban Spoon where
people go and submit their local
businesses real human beings pick up
their phone and they go to the Yelp app
and look for businesses and because real
human beings are using these unlike the
directories of the past this means that
you want to have your business there so
in some ways directories at least in the
local space have returned a great
example of this are local or even
national business associations chambers
of commerce business associations
industry associations and other
directories can be good places now after
all that let's move on to some other
local signals so the first most
important signal is this acronym again
an AP name address and phone number
the key here is that consistency the
next thing is keywords and titles this
is extremely convenient because it's
something you should be doing for SEO
anyway this is particular for title tags
which is something we've covered the
other videos the next one is domain
Authority so if you have an important
domain an important business Google is
going to use this as a signal when
they're doing a traditional local search
so when someone's on their mobile and
they're looking for a good restaurant if
you are an important restaurant in the
city you're going to be more popular in
both local search and traditional search
that's domain Authority the next one is
inbound link signals this again might
sound familiar the things that help you
for traditional SEO do the same for
local the first one is anchor text so
this is one of the most important if
you're a great restaurant hopefully
you're going to have lots of bloggers
lots of magazines and local online
entities that are writing about you and
linking to you
they're naturally going to use your name
and the name of your business in the
review about you these are the kinds of
things that Google is looking for
because these are what is effective
online
the last one is reviews and citations
but in this context these have very
specific definitions it's not just
reviews in general like the ones I've
talked about its reviews on specific
local directories or business listings
and it's both the quality of them are
you getting five stars and the quantity
of them do you have a hundred reviews do
100 people care enough about your
business to review you now the next one
is a bit more complex as it does require
some programming on your website this is
called schema microdata or structured
data schema is an agreed-upon
programming standard by search engines
browsers and device manufacturers that
directs the markup and display of
specific content it's typically content
that is repetitive by nature and
therefore if it's displayed in a
consistent manner for all devices
browsers and operating systems to know
the content then they can display it
properly you find it in addresses
contact cards dates ecommerce products
reviews people places creative works and
more what we're most concerned with here
is the address and phone number by using
schema when you add your address or
phone number to your website it enables
the visitor to use the click-to-call
function on their phone when there's a
phone number on the website in addition
using the address schema can open up a
map when someone clicks on it to show
the location utilizing this schema
provides clear data to the search engine
that can be republished across a variety
of channels now specifically for
Google's business listings they give a
very wide range of content for
businesses to list so fill out as many
areas of the business listing as you can
business hours payment types accepted
phone numbers descriptions reviews from
Google and maybe even from your own
website you can link your social
profiles and any events or promotions
you have one of the biggest signals that
we've seen growing importance are the
amount of pictures that you load into
your business listings in fact Google
provides a report as to how many
the photos are viewed by searchers many
times businesses that have many photos
will show up with more prominence than
those that have little or no photos so
take advantage of the listing
opportunities that Google provides
finally the same behavioral signals that
are used in search are also used in the
local search results and this is because
the search engines especially Google can
see how searchers interact with your
local listing because it is in their
system the behavioral signals start with
how many people search for your business
this is directly related to your local
visibility and loyalty so don't forget
about your local offline marketing next
they measure how long someone views your
listing they count how many times the
phone number is clicked for someone to
call or when someone clicks to find
directions in addition there's a button
there for directions to be sent to a
searchers phone if they're using a PC or
laptop all of these engagement factors
and buttons on a business listing are
counted as engagement and task
completion which increases the
behavioral signals for your business as
people save the listing check-in or even
visit these all send important
behavioral signals of popularity and
loyalty which contributes to your
business's visibility and local search
the key takeaways for this section
local SEO has evolved in pace with the
emergence of mobile devices with
location-aware technologies such as GPS
Bluetooth cell tower triangulation and
IP address mapping an AP is one of the
most important signals and it stands for
name address and phone number some of
the examples of important directories
are Google TripAdvisor Yelp and local
business listings some of the most
important local search results include
on-page signals such as n AP and
keywords completed business information
in business directories and search
engine business listings reviews
citations schema pictures
searcher behavioral signals hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified
click here